le père lorenzo dvd ya et le curé de la
paroisse de cas à couper dans la vie à
au centre de la capitale on l'appelle
pas dre totaux quitte à froisser sa
modestie la ville de buenos aires lui a
décerné le titre de citoyen illustre car
sa mission n'était pas facile rassemblés
dans sa paroisse des braves gens et les
aider à résister à la pauvreté et aux
assauts incessants du narcotrafic
la situation est propice à bien aller la
pauvreté ici remonte à bien des
décennies mais depuis plusieurs années
la politique et l'orientation économique
sont néo libérale dans le pays
il n'y a aucun souci de redistribution
du revenu c'est très clair dans ce
quartier bâti tant bien que mal sur un
ancien bidonville
ça fait longtemps qu'on ne croit plus
aux politiciens qui leur promettent une
bonne vie dans la ville chômage en
hausse inflation à 38% qui ronge les
revenus les familles n'arrivent plus à
joindre les deux bouts
si les anglais et ce n'est pas la famine
les gens ne meurent pas de faim dans la
rue mais ils ont faim dans la mesure où
la demande de la nourriture parce que
l'argent qui leur servait à manger ils
en ont besoin pour le loyer les mines
pour plein d'autres choses qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à se payer alors il
reste le recours à la soupe populaire
on est à deux pas du congrès tous les
soirs de la semaine on distribue un bon
repas équilibrés et moins mal mais
maintenant ça va très mal dit guillermou
il ya quatre ans on servait 130 repas on
en est à 300 plus du double alejandro
pense qu alberto fernandez surtout l'ex
présidente cristina kirchner feront bien
mieux que mauricio macri il était ma
grille macri a tout détruit dit il c'est
un désastre
les économistes sont d'accord pure
incompétence irradié 1600 par des cinq
ans à leurs problèmes
il n'a rien compris marissiaux macri
laisse à son successeur alberto
fernandez une situation économique
catastrophique que le péroniste s'il
applique les politiques habituels de
redistribution sociale risque d'empirer
contrôler les prix les salaires
augmenter la dépense publique au risque
d'hyperinflation donc d'empirer la crise
à deux pas de la résidence
présidentielle qu alberto fernandez va
occuper
il y a des belles terrasses de café mais
sous les arcades plus loin vivent des
familles entières nuitées jours à même
le sol et font ce qu'ils peuvent pour
survivre
ce couple charme les touristes bien sûr
leur art leur permet de survivre
ce n'est pas aussi facile pour des
milliers de petits vendeurs ou survie
comme on peut le travail informel c'est
la dérive du manque d'emplois il
n'apporte aucun revenu à l'état
d'argentine n'est pas au bout de ses
difficultés
jean michel prêtre et du canada buenos
aires